there's a court in japan
that uh just ruled
that the japanese constitution
does not prohibit bans on same-sex
marriage
there are there are this is such a
semantically complex sentence it's it's
hard to even make sense of it
because
for
because the marriage debate was never
about whether or not you should ban gay
marriage it was never about whether or
not you should legalize gay marriage it
was never about whether gay people
should have the right to get married the
marriage debate really was always about
what is marriage
wasn't about hating gay people and
wanting to go
to attack gay people and throw them off
a rooftop it was not about any antipathy
whatsoever it was about a very simple
question that had been simply answered
for all of human history until five
minutes ago the question was what is
marriage
and at the very most basic level i think
every society everywhere forever has
said that sexual difference the
difference between men and women
has something to do with marriage
the complementarity of the sexes the
idea that
you come together and have the
openness to the possibility of life
making a family and having kids that has
something to do with marriage
and it's not that they're
that everyone gets to have a kid it's
not that there aren't problems and
eccentricities in people's marriages but
but marriage looks like something
and then the supreme court in obergefell
anthony kennedy the romantic poet
decided nope doesn't look like that at
all it doesn't mean anything it's
whatever i say it is
love is love equal sign equal sign equal
sign well this court in japan just said
no that's not true the osaka district
court
sided with the argument from the country
of japan
which said that the purpose of marriage
is reproduction and it agreed with the
definition that marriage is a
relationship between a man and a woman
to bear children and raise them together
in cohabitation
osaka said that the marriage system is a
system that exists based on the
pragmatic purpose of the society
protecting men and women to bear
children and raise them that's true why
do i bring this up why do i bring up
this court case from japan
just to remind you this isn't over the
surrender caucus the squishes don't need
to give this up
why have the squishes in the
conservative side gone weak on gay
marriage it's a simple reason and i
sympathize with it because they don't
want to be called phobes they don't and
they don't and they legitimately don't
want to offend their gay friends and
their gay relatives and they don't want
to be seen as haters and bigots there's
nothing there's nothing
hateful and bigoted about saying that
marriage has a meaning
and
people can
pursue pursue happiness as they see fit
and people can
have the intimate relationships as they
like
but
no one has the right
to
redefine reality
to something that it never was and is
not now and never will be
no one has the right it's not good for
anybody it's not right it's not good for
the gay guys it's not good for the
lesbian toys and toy story it's not good
for anybody else it
it doesn't expand marriage and make it
more inclusive it just
destroys marriage
because if marriage has any meaning at
all
it has to have something to do with
sexual complementarity and at least the
possibility the logical possibility of
children
if it doesn't then then what is it
then what and why is it only two people
and why can't it be what's the
difference between a marriage and
a town or a state or a country it's just
relationships of people love is love
there are different kinds of course this
is something that people put off and put
off and put off do not put it off
do it right now it's going to take you
five minutes 10 minutes you're going to
be with the best guys ever who are
protecting so many of us over at the
daily wire epic will if you god forbid
or to drop right now
what would happen to your kids what
would happen to your stuff what would
happen to your life who would make the
decisions for your kids and for your
stuff and for your property and for your
family would it be people you trust
would it be in accordance with your
wishes as you lay it out in your will or
would it be
the state or would it be institutions
that hate your guts and do things to
your kids and your stuff and your family
that you don't want to have done just go
do the responsible thing it takes no
time
it can start at just
119 dollars takes five minutes to set up
go to epicwheel.com by the way you'll
get ten percent off right now if you use
promo code knowles that's k w l e s go
to epic will dot com
use the guys that are protecting so many
daily wire families do it five minutes
you're done it doesn't cost very much
money you get a ten percent discount
code promo code knowles
epicwill.com speaking of
identity politics there's a coffee shop
looking to hire new people
and this coffee shop
puts in their sign to go hire people
they say
white
cis males
are the last choice
when you apply
if you're a black
trans female maybe presumably you'll be
at the top of the list but if you're a
white cis male
you are
the last choice and people know this is
wrong
but this policy already exists
we're all going after this random coffee
shop that libs of tick tock found
the policy already exists it's existed
for decades it's called affirmative
action
and you see it in college admissions and
you see it in hiring
the idea that
white people will be disadvantaged
because of their race
i'm not saying they're disadvantaged in
life i'm not saying oh woe is the white
people i don't know i got a sun tan the
other day i'm not sure i count as a
white person anymore
swarthy people where do we fall on that
i don't know that's a topic for another
day
i'm not saying that there's no the black
people don't have certain
historical baggage in america i'm not
saying that
socioeconomically everyone's on the
level i'm not saying that i'm just
saying at a very practical level there's
a law right the only
the only legal racial discrimination
that you can have is against white
people and to some degree against asians
in favor of black people and mexican
people that's the law and so
yeah the coffee shop is being honest
about it the people shot the coffee
shops being a little provocative and in
your face about it but that's
that's that's the rule for every other
business too just about
so if we have a problem with that if we
think that's unjust then we should deal
with that in our law and say no no more
racial preferences no more racial
discrimination that's wrong it's racist
we used to call that racist now we no we
don't call that racist
i think the majority of people are on
our side there i think the majority of
people get that the squish is dumb
the the
pudding heads who run our institutions
they don't get it but the people do
frankly
even the heads of the liberal
institutions are starting to kind of get
it there was a report just came out of
of mediaite about cnn
it says that cnn's president chris
licked the the new president who took
over for jeff zucker
just told cnn staffers
to stop referring to trump's election
claims that the election was rigged as
the big lie
the cnn staffers just like robots had
been referring to
to trump's questions about the election
as the big lie republicans are pushing
the big lie the big lie and they're
using that because it's a phrase that
was used by hitler and mein kampf but
these guys are so dumb that they don't
realize how hitler was using the phrase
hitler was using the phrase and accusing
the jews of perpetrating a big lie when
they were
uh when they themselves were criticizing
and going after a german general so with
what's ironic about the whole
saga is that cnn was putting itself in
the position of the nazis and
republicans in the position of the jews
but they don't know anything they've
never read a history book they don't
know what they're talking about the
reason that the new president of cnn is
calling for the the staffers to stop
using that phrase
is he he says it's worrisome or i'm
sorry the staffers are saying it's
worrisome that we're being told how to
talk about the worst things ever in
american democracy the president of cnn
is saying guys no one believes this
it's done it sounds dumb most people
know it's not true it's crushing our
ratings even these guys get it the wind
is at the backs of the republicans not
just the republicans the conservatives
not just the conservatives the cultural
conservatives now is not the time
to squish i'm glad you like that clip
now this is very very important don't up
up nope
ring that bell subscribe like ding dong
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe head on over to my myspace
page i don't know go everywhere we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]